so you might wonder what my crowd has to
do with JavaScript but I'm very happy to
announce that we are adding a JavaScript
runtime to Minecraft and we have two
versions that were maintaining one is
built in Java it runs on Windows Mac and
Linux when one built in C++ and it runs
on basically every other platform there
is so this is the bedrock version the
one built in C++ and this basically
means two things so one is changing how
we're shipping UI across all our
products so anything from Android and
now is to switch an Xbox but to maybe
more crucially for you we're exposing
game logic through a JavaScript UI so
you can create Maps mods and custom
gameplay whatever you want I'm gonna
talk about both of these but it's gonna
be more of a case study where we focus
on the first one and really the question
of like how did we even end up here
it might seem completely natural to you
the rat in JavaScript but it wasn't to
us we're gonna talk about how when it up
here how you can work or how we work
with JavaScript and what you will be
able to do in the future and then some
reflections around that but so let's
just start with some context so Mojang
is the company originally behind
minecraft it's 140 people located in
Sweden on the East Coast around here a
country famous for red cottages farms
Bill of the bookshelf about Swedish
meatballs and possibly the awkwardness
of standing in line but hopefully
hopefully also minecraft so we have now
over 90 million active players it's
still growing strong is very strong with
kids around 9:00 to 12:00 but all of us
play Minecraft all ages so just how many
have played Minecraft just raise your
hand okay so one of us that's awesome
and oh sorry there was his life
and of course we all build great things
right we build things like vast
landscapes you might have seen creased
in acts like people building Game Boy
and Game Boys that sort of work and now
we recently added a lot of content to
the oceans so you can start exploring
those so behind this project that we're
talking about today is a small team of
twelve people which is three designers
ten three designers three fronts and
developers and three back-end developers
and we were working on this things we're
working on a big redesign of the UI of
Minecraft because it doesn't look great
it's our honesty this is the current UI
it looks like an homage to the old
Windows 95
look and feel so we were working on
updating the visuals and this is some of
the mocks they were created and we have
a lot of animations going on and we have
this interesting problem of being on
basically every platform so not only
then Windows and Mac but also we're of
course on Android iOS Xbox and switch
and if you think about this is it's an
interesting problem at least as a
designer and someone that builds you I
just think about because the same code
has to not only support a lot of
different screens and screen sizes but
input methods so you have touch gamepad
keyboard and mouse but also any
combination of these two switches
gamepad and touch on a Windows laptop
you might have touch keyboard mouse and
plug-in a gamepad which is a nightmare
so we we started by trying to just
forget it out by building a prototype so
built a prototype early on it looked
like this and we built this with Jekyll
actually I'm not sure if you used it but
it's a great prototyping tool we could
quickly spin up templates and have a
very rude data storage and then we just
use vanilla JavaScript for all the
interactions to figure out like what
happens when you go between this these
different input methods and just to give
some context or like how it is to work
with a game
you are tooling for games heaven
historically have been great you could
imagine like an ocean of different
dreamweaver esque workflows everyone
having their own one no standard that's
basically where we were at and where
most games are at so minecraft has
custom built UI framework styles are
defined in JSON it's inspired by CSS but
also it's nothing like it so we ask this
question can we actually will realize
this fishing in the current framework
and the answer was like maybe but
probably not
but even if we could it would take
forever when it was slow to work with to
it performed not great on a device but
then three it will also difficult to
onboard people because it was completely
arbitrary and custom right so we started
looking at some options of course we
asked ourselves this question early on
can we just embed chromium which no one
should do so we did it and this is the
prototype running and here we just
remove the background and you see it
here running in-game so the prototype
with animated gifs running on top of the
game we got this to work and did an
investigation we ended up thinking this
is actually a bad idea because of a few
reasons but the biggest ones difficult
to support on all platforms we need
basically every single gaming platform
there is to poor mobile performance
especially worried about RAM consumption
didn't look great so I was skeptical to
begin with to be honest I had I had done
a similar journey before when I was at
Spotify we we added one single view as a
web view and just try to evaluate how
that would perform so we tried this on
iOS and it didn't work out great
I had backed away from that slowly and
we there were a few problems with that
so one I didn't perform well - it was
really difficult to mimic all the native
API
and experiences because apple puts a lot
of effort into making things feel a
certain way so just ate a lot of time
and didn't really perform and give us
much value but a few things were
different this time right so when we
tried that iPhone 4s was the latest and
greatest now for Minecraft iPhone 4s is
the lowest performing device that we
support on iOS so performance not as big
of an issue
and going with web to this is slight
sidetrack focus on design but I think it
it might we might learn something from
this I think people have radically
different expectations from an app
versus from a game so we have Google and
Apple publishing a lot of guidelines and
showing us how we should build our
experiences and then also of course
producing a lot of AP is that help us
create coherent experiences but a hair
to those guidelines now that sometimes
creates this effect of apps looking the
same but it's sort of these are five
different apps that's what they're after
right whereas in games every game is its
own universe right they look very very
different
whatever UI they have is not native it's
adapted to that small universe it's
there to tell a story sometimes there's
no UI because that's the best story but
whatever there is it looks more like the
game than the OS so I think as users
versus players we expect an app to feel
native and consistent whatever the apps
but we expect the game you are to tell a
story and just be immersive so a few
users will ever say this game doesn't
feel native so as a developer this gives
us some some freedom to skip native
api's and and set different expectations
maybe we can learn something from that
if we want to pursue web in in other
ways but we thought at least that there
was value in pursuing a web
way of building things so so we continue
looking and we found this framework
called hummingbird built by current labs
I'm going to talk to talk more about it
but basically it's a custom renderer and
then it's the VM JavaScript VM differs
per platform so we we took this
framework we run a bunch of performance
tests this tells you more about I think
our framework that we had then about
hummingbird but the light blue graph
here lower is better and the light blue
is this bedrock our current UI system
and then hummingbird is the photograph
so it looked great we embedded it and
tried it in minecraft so here we can
have live editing of UI and this is not
the cool thing if you're working with
web because that's the tooling we're
used to if you're working with the game
this is the most mind-blowing [ __ ]
you've seen because you have to
recompile usually and it takes forever
so just this demo was great we felt
great about it we also did a very hacky
bridge between the minecraft console and
JavaScript so here just running set with
and changing the UI and the top-left
corner and then running over here
function that just traces your path with
torches so you can run around and paint
your track your tracks extremely useful
so it worked great ish so we give it a
try and it hasn't always been easy
especially when you're like basically
implement implementing a browser you
might be looking to create something
like this but it ends up looking like
this but there's now a tech preview
available it's private but there's gonna
be a public beta soon you can now build
custom UI and custom experiences like
this so we're gonna take a look at that
in a second so what do you do how do you
work with JavaScript HTML and CSS in
Minecraft let's focus on the
first so first of all humbyrd is mobile
optimized so it works well that's why we
picked it too it supports a subset of
HTML CSS and these two are connected so
they are pin aided in what they
implement but whatever they implement
the implement according to the web specs
so we have flex box but we don't have
float because float is expensive so then
the JavaScript vm differ per platform
which means for example that on Windows
on Android we have the eight but in iOS
so I have JavaScript core so it's
basically like building another web page
that we used used to so almost all a
outing is made through flex box that
means of course that anything that is
built for hummingbird will work in a
regular browser but anything built for
the web were probably break horribly in
hummingbird which is annoying at times
but it means a lot to us internally at
least because we can share components
across all our different projects if we
just build them with that in mind and
then it doesn't limit us so we have a
few things that we're building they will
are sharing the same infrastructure so I
have minecraft the game we have websites
for example minecraft.net a lot of
people going there changing their skins
reading news weather launcher that you
launch the java version of minecraft
with this builds with Saif and then
we're building new games and what we're
really doing is we're building a design
system with react then that works across
all of these products across all of
these platforms and we hope that just to
focus a bit on games we we have a lot of
problems actually
we love the react echo system because
there's so much that people are
contributing but we have some unique
problems like we work with game pads
work with sound effects and different
kinds of immersive experiences so we
hope to being able to contribute back
some of this very soon and open source a
few things but I think this if you're
watching and being
or listening and being skeptical it's a
great question like its crowd and
cross-platform rock driven design system
just a pipe dream we might have all read
the Airbnb blog post about sunsetting
react native and and focusing only on
fully native and we're obviously
guessing or taking this bet because we
think we can make it work but it's
difficult to learn from this because we
we have the problem at a different level
a different abstraction so we're running
the same than exact same red code on all
platforms since we're essentially just
embedding a browser which is either
completely bonkers or genius not sure
yet but it's difficult to learn from
that and I think we at least won't have
the same problems like urban D air being
beaded with basically maintaining three
different code bases so one thing that's
great about doing this internally is
that we can let anyone try the in-game
UI without actually having to access the
latest build it can take a lot of time
to build the game obviously so we have
all the documentation running in a
browser so you can view all of our
components and inside of that you can of
course also just boot up the in-game
experience and try it here in the
browser or in a hummingbird player which
is a very thin layer without the game
and try out what the what the latest
state of master is so quickly on
scripting to respond some game logic
this is a fair question what can you do
hopefully basically anything here's a
small demo that we're sharing which is
it has zoomed in now for some reason but
a Final Fantasy X battle system here you
have Steve hanging in a corner looking
at it so we're adding things like camera
controls you can control object entities
mobs we have some parts of the community
all the tweeting some things here's a
short video of
just a generated map and then villager
running inside of that but we have
opened up all the documentation already
so if you're curious to see what you can
do with this encourage you to go to this
URL at least you to the public API that
we've published it's going to change a
lot but you can try it out you can also
download the demo demos that we have
published on these URLs and just to wrap
up some some quick learnings and
reflections like why we're doing this
often get this question was a difficult
decision obviously it was this is a
massive undertaking for a pretty small
team we're burning a lot on a third
party Korean labs and there's not a ton
of precedence within the gaming
community battlefield is actually one of
them though they're also in Stockholm
they are running react they are building
it on top of yoga though by Facebook so
some have tried this but it's very new
to the gaming industry however we're not
really betting on a custom gear
framework at least that's how I look at
it we're betting on open standards we
are head to them and we're betting on
the JavaScript community and as a
designer I'm extremely excited about the
JavaScript community and the design
community meeting and it feels like
we're just seeing the beginning of that
with tools like framework now adapting
reacts and framer X so we have with that
bet on the JavaScript community we're
making hiring easier for us there's a
ton of you and us that have a lot of
experience building UIs there's a
vibrant open-source community there's
great documentation for everything vast
tool in landscape just something like
visual regression testing is a dream
come true for us being able to tap into
that tooling infrastructure and then of
course integrated design tools so
javascript is everywhere we joke
internally at minecraft and say often
that
if it has to CPU it probably runs
minecraft so hopefully maybe these two
things can be combined and I hope that
especially with Minecraft being strong
with kids this choice can introduce
JavaScript to a couple of million kids
thank you
[Applause]